wrapping up our time here at tbs truly
is bittersweet we've had a lot of
incredible guests come by through the
years and uh
this just happened last minute tonight a
good friend of the show
asked if he could say goodbye in person
and this just happened and we said oh my
god this is great ladies and gentlemen
please welcome
nick offerman
uh i just i just want to say from the
bottom of my heart thank you so much for
coming this means a lot to me
it's my pleasure conan i want to
i would like to sincerely congratulate
you on an amazing 28 years
well thank you very much nick i uh
i really appreciate it
is uh is everything okay nick
i'm trying to pull myself together
this show has meant so much to me and as
you can clearly see
i've lost my composure
nick just get a hold of yourself yeah
nick you got to reign it in
i'm sorry gentlemen that you have to see
me like this
this lack of physical control and
hysterical display is nothing short of
an
embarrassment i have to say it's hard to
watch you like this nick
i'll be honest i thought i'd be able to
hold back these tears but instead
what you see before you is a quivering
puddle of a man
a duckling torn from the feathery bosom
of its mother duck
i stand here naked and ashamed
a bald discredit to the offerman name
it's okay nick you'll recover from this
you will no i will not
clips of this blubbering spectacle will
surely go
viral and haunt me michael jordan like
on the world wide web forever
nick people are forgiving you have to
remember no they are not forgiving andy
my high-pitched cater walling and
decadent simpering
will bring me nothing but infinite shame
nick you don't have to do this we can
just go to commercial you will not
go to commercial commerce must wait
i will power through these tears
i've honestly had some of the greatest
memories of my life on this show
and i'd like to invite you to join me to
remember those moments now
those were uh
those really were good times nick well
now the only way
to compose myself and perhaps restore
a shred of my dignity is by spending six
days naked in the woods
if megan calls please tell her i'll be
in the small patch of trees behind the
best buy on sepulveda
in the credit where credits due
department i just want to quickly point
out that uh
in addition to everything else he can do
andy richter is also an amazing writer
and uh we when we were writing this
thing for
nick offerman andy came in the back and
we didn't quite have it and i said andy
we're writing something for nick and you
came over and you sat down and
immediately i said we have a problem
here there's this line we need and andy
went
commerce must wait
that guy
seriously
you know and seriously finally some
angry townspeople of my own